I wanted to take Patrick back even
further to his lover boy Matt well cuz
you know of course he was there can I
take you back thirty years okay
we were on the set of loverboy that was
a long time ago so I want to take you
back to the bar my gosh my little
struggling life right now is to really
understand a woman's need thank God I'm
getting older yes I think if you can
make everyone happy and your partner if
it's whoever your partner is I mean you
want to make them happy we dream he's
been making us happy for a long time and
now with the talk of a sequel to his
2007 film enchanted we're ecstatic my
characters doing extremely well because
look at the size of this kitchen in
Manhattan are you ready for the song and
dance numbers I think that's the best
part it's because you really do the
rehearsal process you take a lot of time
and it's fun to do that it's certainly
anxious to happen I will see I'm waiting
for this ring I think a lot of people do
do your kids get to see you now and
somehow they make fun of me yeah they
don't let me take myself too seriously
which is good the dad of three was
honored with the American Cancer
Society's Impact Award yesterday for his
work with the Dempsey Center the
non-profit Cancer Support Foundation he
helped establish in honor of his mom
Amanda my mother was diagnosed in August
97 finally losing her battle March 2014
Patrick's mission is also setting a good
example for his 17 year old daughter
Tallulah and 12 year old twins Darby and
Sullivan you bring them along and you
show them through the work that we're
doing and let them witness it themselves
and hopefully you can do it by example
that's the best way that's a strong as
well thank you very much
[Music]
love him you know he told me that a
journalist asked him early on in his
career what is it that you stand for
what is your purpose and that really got
him to start thinking led him here to
his life's work so good also you can
help support the American Cancer Society
by making a donation
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]